la droite républicaine très à droite
trop à droite
cette tendance a commencé en 1986 après
l'élection des premiers députés
frontistes l'état leur en tartare 35
députés d'extrême-droite 9,65 % des voix
et un électorat que la droite veut
reconquérir quelques mois plus tard le
ministre de l'intérieur s'illustre avec
la sphère des charters nous avons pris
la décision d'expulser le rpr
s'approprie la thématique phare du fn
l'immigration
alors peut-on dans notre pays parler de
l'immigration en termes vrai où est on
condamné à la langue de moi pas de
langue de bois bien au contraire mais un
discours en 1991 sur les immigrés
polygame qui profitent des aides
sociales
et cette phrase choc si vous ajoutez à
cela le bruit et l'odeur est bien le
travailleur français sur le palier
deviens fou en 1993 le rpr obtient la
majorité à l'assemblée alors que le fn
n'a plus en sièges en 95 jacques chirac
était du président de la république
l'immigration et la sécurité prennent de
l'importance au sein de la majorité de
loi sur l'immigration sont débattus
l'opposition résume cette ligne en trois
mots la lepénisation des esprits
en 2007 nicolas sarkozy succède à
jacques chirac et compte aller plus loin
que son prédécesseur ou un ministère de
l'immigration nationale et de l'identité
nationale
un ministère et un grand débat sur
l'identité nationale qui virent
rapidement un grand débat sur l'islam
l'opposition dénonce une dérive et au
sein même de l'ump
les ténors se fâche nom de quoi les
stigmatiserait tombe et leur refuserait
t'on le droit d'exercer leur religion
j'ai pas tout à fait la certitude que le
débat soit conçu dans cet esprit voilà
ça qui me préoccupe la fracture entre
membres du parti aura contribué à la
défaite de nicolas sarkozy à la
présidentielle de 2012 aux législatives
pour se relever
l'ump hésite à s'allier au front
national on n'a pas à se pincer le nez
lorsqu'on parle du front national qui
est effectivement un parti républicain
sinon il serait interdit
on n'a pas de sens pour l'instant et ça
n'a pas de sens d'évoquer ce sujet à ce
moment en 2017 après son élimination au
premier tour de la présidentielle
françois fillon annonce qu'il votera
contre marine le pen donc pour emmanuel
macron par dépit ces parties de ce j'ai
dit je cache pas qu'ils auraient
souhaité que et qui sont battus pour ça
que la position du bureau politique soit
plus nette depuis l'élection d' emmanuel
macron le party les républicains et
tyrannie il y a ceux qui ont rejoint le
rassemblement national comme thierry
mariani
ceux qui ont rejoint en marche ont
décidé de travailler avec la majorité
quant à ceux qui restent après avoir
tenté la droite dure toutes les tares
défini
[Musique]